the
OG crypto derivatives platform and the
best place to buy your Bitcoin
hey guys and welcome back to the Leia
hail pen show we are back doing our
virtual interviews and I'm so excited
for this episode now before I bring on
my guess I do want to let you know that
this podcast is sponsored by bitmex
bitmex is the OG crypto derivatives
exchange and now has a spot exchange for
you to buy and sell your Bitcoin
especially in a bear Market you really
need a name that you can trust and
bitmex sets the standard for reliability
performance and transparency and of
course has proven itself through
multiple bare Cycles so that's very
important now right now BMX is actually
celebrating the start of bitmex spot
with one million dollars in USD to give
away so to enter all you have to do is
trade the equivalent of 250 dollars and
so you can grab some Bitcoin during the
crash for 250 you can actually enter up
to 25 times and one lucky winner can
even receive five hundred thousand
dollars in Bitcoin I think that sounds
pretty great so um if you do want to get
involved all the information for you is
is um in the description on YouTube so
definitely check out bitmex that is the
best place to buy your Bitcoin now
before I bring on my guest today please
don't forget to hit the like button and
hit subscribe as we are having
conversations that sort of not allowed
to have so I'm very excited uh to do
this now joining me today is the
co-founder of the well-known brexit
movement he's a former Tuscan Police
Officer he's the founder of the Tatum
report he's also a CEO speaker and
entrepreneur it is Brandon Tatum Brandon
welcome to the show ah thank you for
having me
absolute pleasure I'm really excited
um you have done so much
um I'm I love what you're doing the
movement that you're starting and that
you're a part of
um so before we get into all of that I'm
really curious how did you make the jump
from police officer to entrepreneur and
starting your own channel
well it's an interesting story I have to
first say that I think that God was had
an instrumental part in in you know
constructing that I started out you know
uh as a football player I was an
All-American football player coming out
of high school I was the top player in
the nation one of the top players in the
nation I went to college I play football
in college and I just knew I was going
to play in the NFL and and you know just
like other things in life adversity hit
things don't turn out the way you
believe I was in a 2010 NFL draft didn't
get drafted football wasn't working out
for me and so I decided to become a
police officer and that was a pretty
interesting story on how I became a
police officer giving my background
however I did a ride along and I was
inspired I rode with the officer named
Sean Payne I said man this is a hero and
I want to be a hero like Sean so I
joined the police department I was a
police officer for six and a half years
I was on the SWAT team I was a field
training officer I taught officers how
to become officers as a field as a fto
oh I wish I which I just said before and
then while I was a police officer I
began to become a lot more political you
know I wasn't politically involved I
didn't follow politics or anything like
that but I started to become more
political because of my co-workers with
informed me that hey man I think that
you need to be more involved this is
what you believe that your stance is
this is what you really believe you know
based on your Christian faith and so I I
started to get into uh looking at the
Republican Democrat Party and all of
that I made a video about a Donald Trump
rally that I went to in 2016 and it went
viral I mean people were just amazed at
what I had to say just my genuine
approach and perspective from just
showing up at a rally not watching it on
television not believing what everybody
said I actually showed up and went there
and I was impressed went viral so I
started making videos as a police
officer and they were all doing very
very well 2017 I made a video about
Colin Kaepernick because I was very
disappointed in his approach to Nilan
from the national anthem and that went
Mega viral that video has 70 million
views and so that opened up the
opportunity for a company out of Anthem
Arizona they offered me a position to be
the spokesperson of their conservative
Tribune Network and I accepted the job
it was supposed to be only one year I
said hey I'm gonna go and try this and
I'll go back to being a police officer
then I met Candace Owens me and kenzone
started brexit then we worked for
Turning Point USA and then it just began
to grow in that way and I always had an
entrepreneurial Spirit you know when I
got saved I believe the sky's the limit
I believe if you go out and pursue
Excellence you can accomplish it and it
can become a reality and so even when I
was a cop I wanted to do greater things
and so now the opportunity presented
itself where I could no longer be a cop
I mean I was I was already far removed
from it and then I said you know what I
want to start my own clothing company I
want to you know I want to start my own
network for news I want to build my
YouTube channel which we've been able to
build to about 2 million so subscribers
and and it's just been me going up in an
upper trajectory ever since
it's just so amazing and I think that's
so fascinating that you started out um
as a police officer particularly because
of all the hate that we're seeing right
now towards officers and we'll get into
that you know the whole all cops are bad
thing we'll get into that um but I
wanted I want to understand more about
black set because there's this I so I'm
British but something that I'm noticing
um in America is this um Obsession
between race and division
um and I'm not I'm not understanding why
somebody like President Biden would say
you know you're not black if you don't
vote for me that for me is just like so
mind-blowing so why was brexit so
necessary what is the issue here in the
states
well yeah in the states we have a
tremendous issue with politicians lying
and being fake and we have an issue
of misrepresenting political positions
because people are under the impression
that the Democrat Party
is the party of the people they actually
are the party of slavery and then you go
through the Democrat platform and they
have been
terrible to black people all these years
for some reason they've been able to
brainwash a lot of people into believing
that they really care about them more
than the Republican Party
so when you look at the political
perspective brexit all we want to do is
get people to open their eyes to what is
true not necessarily a political party
we could care less what political party
you're part of we just want you to know
the truth and so when you're going out
and you're looking at voting or you're
looking at building a family
we want to make sure that you are
becoming the best version of yourself
the most informed and you're a leader in
the community and so we're trying to
raise up a generation of people or help
raise a generation of people
um that are truth Seekers and they can
go out and become the best version of
themselves by relying on the truth and
not political correctness and all this
other stuff that we see in the United
States of America But to answer your
point about somebody like Joe Biden is
that these people in my opinion many of
these politicians are worried about
re-election they're worried about
pushing an agenda they don't really care
about people and one of the ploys that
the Democrat Party has had on on black
people in America is that they have been
brainwashing black people or threatening
them and making them feel bad and
humiliating them if they don't vote for
Democrats and so when Joe Biden tells on
Charlemagne the guy's show he says if
you don't know if you want to vote for
me or Trump then you ain't black that
means your whole identity and purpose is
is associated exclusively with Democrats
matter what they do or say it's
exclusively Associated and I think it's
disgusting and in our country we really
need to see a change where people can
start uniting instead of being separated
on color lines religion and all this
other crazy stuff that's really
superficial in the grand scheme of
things
I just think saying something like that
is just from my perspective is like the
epitome of racism like we actually had a
British politician um and she's Indian
and she called a black politician
superficially black the other day
because he spoke well and because he is
very well educated like how where's that
cognitive dissonance like how did they
not realize like that is so insulting
well it's a it's a concept called
brainwashing like well people if you
just say you grew up in an environment
and all you see on the television is a
certain perspective being pushed towards
you all you listen to on the music all
you see in in movies all you hear from
the politicians that are actually
present in your community that you begin
to be brainwashed into believing that uh
the illusion is actually true and
when these people come out and they say
outlandish things because of the
brainwashing and because of your
identity being associated with these
people being your friends when you see
them do something it's almost impossible
for you to come out and say well wait a
minute the guy in which I've been voting
for supporting and I believe that was
the the contributing factor to my
success it's a racist what am I going to
do with this and and so people they they
continue to like evade the issue you
know they say in our country that Donald
Trump is some racist crazy person Donald
Trump has never said that if you don't
know who you want to vote for you ain't
black he has never said and and Joe
Biden has made mention that Hispanics
are more open-minded than black people I
mean all of these uh
terms that that he's painting black
people with a broad brush is in my
opinion racist and I'm gonna say this
uh Joe Biden Hillary Clinton Barack
Obama went to the funeral of a former
Clans member named Robert Byrd also
there's other uh racist individuals who
are historically racist in our country
that were mentors to Hillary Clinton and
Joe Biden so I think a lot of people are
waking up when somebody like myself tell
the truth and present it to them they go
do the research but it is a generation
of brainwashing that is going on that's
caused this to be uh the way it is in
our country
what about the did you have any backlash
when you started brexit from other black
members of your community
oh 100 I mean when I when I came out and
made a video about Donald Trump I mean I
got tremendous backlash people at my
church quit talking to me people that
went to school with quit talking to me
saying to my Uncle Tom [ __ ] sell out and
all I did was go to the rally and listen
to what the man said and I said I agree
with everything he's saying and to be
honest a lot of people do but because of
social pressure they can't you know but
I got a lot of backlashing even in
Blackshear there's a lot of people
hating on us oh y'all don't really y'all
not in the black community and all this
old crazy stuff that they say but we
have over 40 I think we are 43 almost 45
chapters all over the country so we're
in 45 different states I mean we're
we're progressing we're growing all over
the country because people can get with
the message of Truth and and not and not
Division and all this other stuff that
we see so we get backlash but you know
it's just the way it is you know Jesus
they hated Jesus anybody that's
successful anybody that's doing
something that breaks the mold or make
people feel uncomfortable because
they're too afraid to pursue they get
uncomfortable and they say things to you
so it you know it doesn't bother us at
all but it does happen
so I've been following a lot of your
content
um and you talk a lot about work culture
um so I'm interested to know what would
you say the biggest issue in American
society is right now
um I think cowardice I think a lot of
people are cowardice
um they are afraid to stand up for
what's right versus Standing Up For What
the mob wants them to believe right so
if you come out and you see a situation
where you see drag queens performing in
front of little kids you know Stevie
Wonder can see that there's something
wrong with that however because most
people are too afraid to get counseled
they are too afraid to say anything
because they don't want to be transfer
homophobic and all this stuff they sit
back on the sideline and they allow
these atrocities to continue to be
pursued in our country which leads to a
slippery slope so I say a lot of people
were raised to be strong what race to be
uh confident and stand for what's right
people are raised to follow the mom and
shut up and if everybody's going left
you need to go left and not be seen and
I think that that is causing a lot of
confusion and Chaos in our country and
we've seen it in Nazi Germany the same
thing I mean people probably knew that
what Hitler was doing was crazy but
people don't want to say anything
because it's the it's the popular way in
which to respond to society is to follow
this even though it was really following
the dictator off a cliff uh murdering
innocent people so we have we deal with
the exact same thing in the United
States of America just not to that
extent but I think that it could get to
that extent if we don't make a change
it's interesting that you say you think
a lot of people are um just following
the mob because I sort of feel like
people actually believe this stuff like
in the name of doing good right like
I think the other day I saw you talking
about um the the transgender teacher who
had the fake breasts the man
um and like saying that that's bad is is
not is not allowed I mean I'm kind of
confused I I do think people are
brainwashed and actually do believe this
stuff like I think they think it's okay
well I think that what's happening is
that they are some of them are afraid to
have an opinion right so when you look
at a man
that was last year he was a man now some
there were some reports and some rumors
that this guy is really trolling or
whatever but anyway you see a person
that's a man he's a masculine individual
one year and the next year he's not only
a woman but he's a woman with jugs that
are coming out way out here like they
want to drag on the ground and they're
fake they're not even real and they're
just over the top any rational person
will look at that and say
something is not right with what this
person is doing I something is wrong
with this person but nobody's gonna say
that because according to the school
policy they are in in total uh agreeance
with whatever position that this guy
wants to be in because he's a part of
the protected class according to that
particular school's uh laws or bylaws
you cannot have a shirt that expose your
nipples or areola you can't have a shirt
that exposed those things he is doing
exactly what the school district says
you the students cannot do but like I
said if a person comes out and says that
is wrong they will get bombarded so
you'll transforming you so that I think
there's some people that are afraid to
think for themselves right and then they
fall into a Half Baked perspective on
these things right they've not thought
it through if you talk to many people
about transphobia what is transphobia
they have not thought it through they
know the talking points they know what
the classmates are saying they will
regurgitate that in a in a
um you know a spontaneous interview but
when you ask them to think it through
they have no real answer because they
haven't thought about it so I do think
that people actually believe some of
this stuff in a Half Baked
um you know mentality
um yeah and in terms of these narratives
that are being pushed right now
um mainly I would say from the left what
would you say is like the biggest lie
that we're that we're being told to
believe right now
oh my God there's so many uh I would say
that America's is systemically racist
that that's that's the biggest lie that
they've ever told in in our second to
well I would say a close second is
climate change and then uh I I don't
know what the third one would be
um but America is racist like I mean
that's that's the most ridiculous
perspective I have ever heard of I have
never experienced racism in my life and
I have experienced people saying racist
things to me but it has zero power it
has no power over me like a guy called
me to inward when I was a police officer
so what was somehow I can't arrest you
now somehow you know I'm gonna go home
and lose my paycheck and I can't even
you know exist in America because you
called me a name that's no different
than you calling me a b word uh uh the
economy stupid or whatever it's just a
word in America today racism has no
power over people you know and I think
it's very obvious you know we had a
Barack Obama was voted overwhelmingly as
the first black president of the United
States of America and it was a ton of
white people Republicans voted for him
so you know it's a myth but they needed
to be true so they can push propaganda
and and isolate Us in different areas
black you against white hispanic you're
against black you know we're all against
each other and they make every every
cycle they can say you know what we're
going to solve this problem of racism
we're going to solve this problem black
people are not treated fairly in America
it's like it's the dumbest thing ever we
get treated I mean look look at the
things we've been able to accomplish I
mean look at some of the most popular
people in the United States of America
are black athletes and black rappers are
entertainers I mean people will
literally worship at their feet if they
sought them in public it's just it's
just not a true uh sentiment and a true
experience here in America
so there's an important distinction to
be made then um in terms of racism
versus institutional racism like racism
exists like sexism exists like anything
exists right
um but the institutional side is
different that's what you're saying
there's a huge distinction yes yes
there's some Knuckleheads and a
cornfield running in circles that hate
black people for some research news or
whatever you know there's people who
have this hatred in them it's never
going to stop some people hate women
some people hate successful people you
know some people hate poor people I mean
the hate is human nature is never going
to stop but to say that this is systemic
meaning that there's a there's a
perpetuation of it or it's systematic
meaning that there are systems in place
that are uh allowing racism in our
country it's absolutely ridiculous if
you do a crime against a person because
of their race you will be charged with a
hate crime if you refuse to allow a
person's service in this country because
because of their race you are
discriminating against them and your
business license will be taken away from
you so it it there there's systems in
place to prevent racism in America and
hold people accountable who do exercise
racism here so it's it's a big it's a
big lie and let me say this I think the
LIE is also that is pervasive meaning
that it's a lot of racism going on it's
like that's not true there's like a few
people that are racist many people who
probably are racist never are outwardly
racist because they can't be in their
heart like I don't like black people I
don't like white people but in in the in
their normal everyday practice it's
almost impossible to pursue that the
same thing with Law Enforcement Officers
there may be some racist cops at that
it's like I can't stand black people I
don't want to patrol this area anymore
but in their actions they literally have
to put their lives online to protect
black people in the inner city
communities so you know it's it's I
think that I wish that we would change
the narrative here in the United States
of America
how um how destructive is it to the
black community to keep telling them
that they're oppressed and that the
world hates them it's it's completely uh
uh paralyzing immobilizing because if
you grow up thinking well I mean
everything is against me being the the
lenses that you see the world through is
a negative lens which will lend you
negative results if your mind is always
I'll never be a doctor because black
people can't be doctors in the country
every time you get pulled over by a
police officer I'm gonna die because I'm
black you know it just it's and you you
live in a sense of trauma without
actually experiencing any trauma you're
you're projecting that you're gonna
experience things that are not even true
and then the young men who grow up black
and they don't believe in pursuing
Excellence because why would you why
would you want to be a billionaire why
would you want to be the biggest
investor Mogul in in the world because
you believe that somehow a white man is
going to hold you down so you don't
pursue
and therefore only the elite rise to the
top and not an influx of of people that
are everyday folks that work hard in
this country do the right thing stay out
of Criminal Justice System get get
married before having children all of
those things we we suppress them and
they and it's this uh victimhood
mentality and generational trauma that
gets passed down to different people and
that's why you see I think generally
speaking you see people in the black
community just not accelerating like
other communities
so how does brexit aim to I guess just
break all of that down and sort of uh
Inspire the younger generation to do
better
it's through education because the
biggest problem is that people are not
educated it's just like if somebody was
going uh into you know uh doing Bitcoin
if you don't know if you don't know
anything about it you're not educated
you don't have anybody to teach you're
not going to be as successful and it's
the same thing about America about life
about history if you're not educated on
what the truth is how can you then
proceed forward in the most you know
profitable way or the most you know say
methodic
way in which you could be successful
right so I think that with brexit we
want to educate people what is the true
history in the United States of America
how do you build your credit how do you
uh function as a father in a family what
is the most important uh way in which to
succeed how do you have integrity you
know how did our forefathers do such
great things in in the early in the late
1800s early 1900s who was Booker T
Washington why is he an important figure
if he could do it you can do it you know
Booker T Washington developed the
Tuskegee uh Institute you have George
Washington Carver who is one of the
greatest inventors of all time Ben
Carson who was one of the the greatest
neurosurgeons of all time to ever
existed pediatric neurosurgeon and
nobody's ever done anything
nobody has ever done
um to the extent they have not done what
Ben Carson has done when it comes to his
particular medical field and so learning
about those things understanding what
success looks like and then you can say
go out in the world and be prosperous
looking through the lens of reality and
success and not victimhood and racism
it all sounds really good to me I I
don't know why um they uh they're not
okay with it I don't know why they're
trying to keep everybody down well I
guess I know why they're trying to keep
everyone down control obviously
um you mentioned climate change uh
that's a Hot Topic
um why do you think climate change is a
lie well I just don't see the
consistency there when you look at the
climate sign the climate scientists of
many of them disagree I have seen
scientists that say climate change is
real and we are going to die if we don't
do something about it and I see
something that says in carbon emissions
at this point is inconsequential to
climate change there's no there's no
legitimate tie to to a climate
temperature increase
um to carbon emissions so when you when
you look at both sides you say I don't
know which one is right how are they
picking one side and not
um you know listening to these other
scientists that are contradicting the
ones that they are holding up on a
pedestal and they're all equally
qualified and then I also look at common
sense now I could be wrong but I'm a man
of Common Sense scientists claim that
the world has been around for billions
of years we have only been emitting
carbon into the atmosphere for probably
the last hundred years you're saying
this explain me billions of years in a
hundred years of these little tiny cars
Plumping carbon emission out into the
atmosphere in a world that's primarily
filled with water and and it's not even
uh um like in Africa look at the
continent of Africa how many people
driving cars in Africa that's the
biggest continent in the world you know
you got places that are desolate people
don't even people aren't even driving
it's not even as prolific of motor
vehicle transportation in a condensed
area like China or somewhere like that
it it so and this is just my opinion
because I'm allowed as a as an American
citizen to have an opinion about these
things it just does not sound
reasonable to me and then when you look
at their approach to it you say okay
India China has 80 percent of carbon
emission eighty percent of all the
carbon emissions that they claim is
causing global warming we're only a
small fraction of it okay that's fine
what are we doing about it now if they
wanted to be competitive in the market
and say let's create clean energy let's
do electric cars let's have it compete
against uh diesel engines and V12 uh
supercars let them compete in the
marketplace and and may the best man win
that's not what they're doing they're
saying we need to get rid of every car
except electric we need to go clean
energy and solar panels and when you
look at it you say where they plug in
the electric cars into they're plugging
it into a system that's burning coal I
mean Burning uh fossil fuels they're
lying to you if you look at California
California only a third of their uh
charging ports are working in San
Francisco
and then they're talking about making
every car in in California electric and
being electric had that little heat wave
that came through I mean California had
the heat wave that came through and they
have to the governor is selling the turn
the air condition off because it's too
much Demand on the system now how on
God's green earth are you going to have
millions of electric cars and you can't
even have a five five a five degree
temperature increase over the weekend
without completely destroying the system
and and it just makes me feel like these
people have an agenda it's a money
making strategy for them they keep us in
fear it was coveted and now it's climate
change again and so it that those are
the things that make me very skeptical
could there be a true to climate
increase or whatever it may be but the
way they're presenting I have no clear
evidence that nothing that they're
saying is true and so I'm going off of
my logic and reasonableness to come to a
conclusion until I see something
unequivocal yeah I mean you only need to
see how they all just get on their own
private jets uh and fly across the world
um to talk about the climate if it was
that bad they could do it on a zoom
meeting you know I don't know why they
couldn't talk about it on a zoom call
100 David Newsome is flying to private
jet places right it is he tells the city
he comes on a thing he says please help
us make sure you turn your electric to
78 degrees it's not even that bad and
then the LA Rams have a football game at
a facility with 80 000 people burning
electricity like he's going out of style
it's like how how is electricity so bad
in in the city or at least in especially
in La when you got a facility with a
with a TV screen that was like 20
billion dollars to build this 3920
billion it was like several hundred
million dollars to build this TV screen
at wrap around the stadium 80 000 people
in this in this Arena full of lights and
entertainment and I mean they probably
spent they probably spent a hundred
thousand dollars every time they turn
the lights on in that place it's the
most power-sucking place in probably all
of Metro LA
but it's totally fine you can have
football games but you gotta you know
turn out turn your life down just
because it's too much Demand on the
system these people are hypocrites oh
for sure you know watch what they do uh
not what they say
um drag queen Story Hour is actually
um a thing which has been blowing my
mind
um it's sort of the new favorite idea
and it's kind of escalated from uh drag
queen's Story Hour to children now
having the privilege of seeing them
twerking in front of them
um it's so wild so what is your take why
do you think they they need children to
accept this ideology so much like it
really has pushed on the kids
because I think there's a bigger agenda
here it's not like some innocent people
just trying to entertain and have a good
time no they have a methodic plan to to
get to the children and and and change
the Next Generation to be more accepting
to their pedophilia and I'm telling you
right now people probably think I'm
crazy this lgbtq movement not the people
because there's some people that are gay
whatever they're just trying to live
their life but the movement has an
agenda and there's certain people behind
this agenda to push pedophilia in
America they started out by saying we
just want to love who we love let us
come out and be gay okay that's fine
okay now we want a civil union now that
mean we want to be is in a similar
relationship like marriage okay okay no
no now we want marriage now we have to
redefine marriage in America redefine
biblical marriage to accommodate and now
we don't just want to get married now we
want 45 genders and now we don't just
want 45 genders now we want kids to
transition at seven years old
and now kids can't change this in seven
year old now we want to change the term
from pedophilia to minor attractive
persons
and then now we don't want to just have
drag shows for adults we want children
to participate in drag shows and now we
don't just want to drag queen to read
Story Hour we want to start stripping in
front of the kids I mean this is a
slippery slope that's leading to
pedophilia and if you look at any
historical generation of people it don't
have to be just the United States of
America we're a very new uh development
of a society you look at history I mean
pedophilia has been around since the
beginning of the time men have been
taking advantage of young women and
children from the beginning of time we
see priests in the Catholic Church
taking advantage of young boys we see uh
Jeffrey Epstein have an island where he
he's taking little kids and sex
trafficking into them in in Clinton and
other people on this airplane flying
there with him we don't know what they
did but they on the plane with him going
to pedophile Island this guy's the most
prolific pedophile in the United States
history and he ended up dying
mysteriously in the jail with no guards
as they fell to sleep but you know you
see things like this and you're like
there is a sick demonic anti-god agenda
that is being pushed and we are thinking
let's just Live and Let Live but they
are pushing something completely
different there is no reason that an
adult thinks it's appropriate to shake
his you know what in front of little
children
what grown man think that makes sense
and then dressing like a woman while
doing it it's it's it's crazy to me it's
an agenda there
you say uh this beautiful agenda but
like whose agenda is it like who is
behind all of this
I think it's the Godless amongst us and
I think a lot of it is the progressive
left so the progressive left in our
country they're Godless they don't want
God to be retained in our Consciousness
many of them don't even believe in God
and so when you don't believe in God
you're susceptible to the enemy and I
think that their God is the government
their God is themselves and the wicked
mind of the of the average person can
concoct all kinds of ridiculous things
and in their pursuit to Rebel directly
against God they're like so for instance
goddess says marriage is between a man
and a woman they don't want God so they
say marriage is between whoever you want
it to be you know there's a there's the
the sanctity of life right when you look
at the abortion situation they instead
of them saying Life Starts at conception
and we're just okay with murdering they
want to do the exact opposite you should
be able to murder all your children
until they're you know whatever until
they're born hey some of them even even
think post post-birth abortion is is
reasonable but you know so the the total
rebellion of God is what caused them to
go down in slippery slope of of
ridiculousness evilness and also
pedophilia and and falling after their
own sexual lusts and all of the above
and I think that's it's just it's the
Rebellion against God that's creating
this and some of these people may not
understand that they may be thinking
they're doing the right thing but
they're really falling down a slippery
slope
so let's go into this religion uh area a
little bit more
um it is interesting because
um America is has a very strong uh
religious kind of like tone to it there
are a lot of uh Christian Republicans
um so what is that connection then
between
um a lack of religion
um and then liberal Behavior
see I liken it to lack of relationship
right because a lot of people have
relationships with God and especially in
judeo-christian in a judeo-christian
perspective it's having a relationship
with Jesus Christ Our Lord and Savior
right so people who are truly Christian
are pursuing the Christian message they
understand that personal relationship
they understand accountability they want
to live right they want to be uh saved
they want salvation all of these things
but you follow the message of Jesus
Christ which is you know uh being
married and treating people the way you
want to be treated love your neighbor
and all these different things that made
our country develop into what it is
today being a great country however
unfortunately everybody's not following
that path so then you have people who do
not have a savior do not have God do not
have the spirit of God retained in their
Consciousness and they begin to lose uh
uh Humanity because think about it you
say I'm just gonna break a couple points
from the Bible you say the Bible says
you should not fornicate you should get
mad married before you have children
there's a lot of people that are
suffering right now because they had
children out of wedlock and they're not
married so they're not raising children
in a two-parent home and if you look at
the statistics in the United States of
America and probably around the world
fatherless homes are contributing
factors to people going on drugs suicide
everything else so just one principle if
we followed we will see a better pursuit
of excellence in our country and and
there's more like that it's cheating
stealing adultery
if we would follow one of those things
we would be a better country however
these other people on another side they
followed their own intuition and
instincts which leads them to inhuman
inhumane things now America because we
still have residue from Christianity
spilling off on people who don't even
believe in God versus you having places
around the country where they're
beheading people and throwing people off
of building and throwing people to death
and raping and killing and pillaging
people and scalping them in other places
around the world we have to spill off of
the godliness in the United States of
America and in some places in Europe
um that keeps our society
from being completely barbaric and you
know I think that religion plays a
tremendous role if you look at any of
the major leaders even our Founders in
this country we're all religious
Christian judeo-christian believe in
people and some of some of them let's
let's go back to slavery we talk about
slavery in this country and it was bad
yeah okay it started in Africa Africans
enslaved each other and sold them around
the world so they can't blame the white
man for the origination of slavery but
however when they got here a lot of the
uh the people who were pursuing ending
slavery the people who helped Harriet
Tubman in the Underground Railroad they
were Christian folks abolitionists who
helped abolish slavery in this country
so if it wasn't for the Abolitionist
Christian you know we would still be in
in a position where we would be
um having slaves and doing stuff that
some of these other countries are still
doing today even though others don't
want to acknowledge it so you know
that's just my perspective I think God
is a contributing factor to success and
the rebellion of God creates this
environment where people are so Lawless
and they they don't have any any stable
environment to attest to right they
don't know how many genders they don't
know what they believe they don't know
if you should love a man or a woman they
don't know who they are they don't have
a sense of identity they're falling to
their own devices
I think the older I get the more I
understand uh religion like the more it
makes sense like I'm not particularly
religious but I I you know I get it like
the family values you know no no sex
before marriage you know everything it
it makes sense the older I get
um do you think people who aren't
religious can
um like I don't say be saved because I
think that's too much of a religious
word for me but like you know not go so
woke and liberal and crazy
um it's religion the only way
well see you got to understand this you
have to say as a person you says you say
as you get older you realize the value
of these things and so you know you got
to say you realize the value of marriage
you realize the value of treating
somebody the way you want to be treated
all of those things are Christian values
and so although you may not associate
religiously you still are understanding
the principles of Christianity so you
may not be religious but you still uh
you know our
affected by the religious context
because outside of the Bible there is no
you should be married who said we should
be married you know who said you
shouldn't steal or kill somebody who
said that humans don't say that because
we've been killing people from the
beginning of time they're killing people
right now in other countries with no
mercy they eating people you know like
you go to places in the continent of
Africa they'll kill you genocide like
the human nature is okay with killing
people the human nature is okay with
having 50 wives than human nature but
see what which what you may be
understanding as you continue to to grow
and and get experiences is that you are
actually
um and subconsciously adopting Christian
principle
and you don't have to be a religious
zealot to do that that's the beauty of
Christianity because it's about your
personal relationship people get caught
up in a in in this world of thinking you
have to be religious meaning you have to
go to a church you have to do this you
have to do that it's not that it's that
you begin to see in your Consciousness
what's right and what's wrong and that
to me is when you pursue God in your own
life where you say look let me read the
Bible I don't have to be come and say
I'm a Christian and none of this other
stuff that stuff is Superfluous thing
that are made up by mankind but when you
start to get that inkling that feeling
you start to see it and you say okay
these principles do make sense well why
where did this come from it's almost
like a historical uh research where did
these things come from let me read the
Bible and when you read the Bible you'll
see wow this is where this comes from
wow this is not some fairy tale book
where you know there's happy stories
that no this is this is a real book of
people having experiences all across the
world and never knew each other that are
that are the same collective experience
and you know if I don't know if you've
ever read the Bible but people may think
that the Bible is like this book of
mysteries and like there's this happy
stories of perfection and no no it's
like it's like a soap opera you know uh
uh everybody in the Bible was messing up
even the ones that were God's favorite
people were just was terrible sometimes
and in it all in in our end right Jesus
was murdered on a they hung him on the
cross which is the worst way to die back
in those days all of the apostles were
murdered because of their faith so it's
not some little book to make you feel
good it's actually a books that are
compiled together with I would think
inspiration to help people navigate to
their personal relationship with God and
I think that religion has really hurt
people in that because you look at it
and you go well I don't want to be a
Christian because Christians do this so
I don't want to be a Jew because Jewish
people do this I don't be a Muslim
because it's like no no there is a God
in heaven or wherever you want to call
it that that has that can have a
personal connection with you that you
can build on you can talk to you can
pray to whatever you want to do meditate
to or whatever but the but the
acknowledgment is that there is a higher
power up here that you could have a
personal relationship with outside of
religion so and I'm not here to preach
to you but I just see it in you I see
you saying you know these are things
that I'm doing I'm like
this is where you personally nobody has
to know you ain't got to talk to nobody
about it you ain't got to tell nobody
you ain't got to declare today I'm a
Christian I'm unborn again
it's a time where you where you within
yourself when you meditate or whatever
you do in the morning or whatever you
say well God
if you real if you're a God
then I want to get to know you
personally I want to get to know you
better what is the truth who am I what
is my purpose you know that's the beauty
of a relationship with God it's not this
religious crap people have gone too far
with this man and then they hate each
other right my religion is better than
your religion I'm really true what my
words say are really honest and yours
are not really
it's all you know just get your personal
relationship and I think that God is is
definitely you know uh pursuing you but
anyway let me get off that subject no
it's good I'm actually Jewish so uh are
you Jewish okay yeah yeah yeah so no but
it's it's for me I think like
Christianity Islam and Judaism like I
think they're practically the same um
they will come from the same place um so
I know the Old Testament are you
Orthodox Jewish are you are you it's
different in England I'm just it's
different I'm just Jewish like
ethnically Jewish born Jewish culturally
Jewish yeah like just culturally Jewish
Friday night dinners family Jewish
school you celebrate and you you go you
stab it not really not anymore like when
I was younger yeah at home with my
parents not anymore maybe when I'm
married I don't know I'll maybe I'll
bring it back but yeah I don't know but
um no I think I think a lot but what but
I think the point is a lot of the look
you spoke about Christian Judea values
they're literally you know they're the
same um and I think a lot of those
values the order I get as I was saying
make sense now
um like I understand you know like it
might be human nature let's just say for
like a man to have multiple wives but
like religion brings brings it back to
how it needs to be in order to have like
that flourishing Society
um and that sort of what makes sense now
I guess
um but in terms of everything that we've
spoken about and how Society is
um
to what extent would you say uh big Tech
is sort of involved in this narrative
like I saw actually the other day
um you know PayPal they they um banned
the account of gays against groomers
which was just crazy
um so I'm interested to hear your take
on big Tech and you know how involved
they are I'm pushing certain narratives
yeah I mean they're complicitly involved
in pushing a narrative and working on
behalf of the left I mean that's pretty
much what it is you can you can see it
anywhere I got banned on Tick Tock it's
just the craziest thing ever I just
literally posted the videos that I post
on my YouTube I'm not being on YouTube
I post the same videos on Tick Tock and
I'm banned and I didn't even know I was
banned I just logged in one day and they
said you've been permanently banned you
know and I see this more often and you
have to ask the question well why are
they Banning I'm listen there are people
doing pornography on Tick Tock pretty
much on Instagram for sure
Twitter for sure people are doing
pornography on these sites and they're
not banned it's like if I say that I
think that this is a mental illness or I
think this and you and I'm banned but
you saying people can be nude on your
website and not be banned I mean it's
it's it's absolutely asinine but I think
people should realize that it is an
agenda these people that work for these
big tech companies want to push an idea
we already saw through an investigation
that or hopefully they play out the
investigation more that the FBI was in
communication with Facebook
and they were talking about what
information should be silenced and what
shouldn't be silenced according to a
current a certain administration's
perspective that is that is that is
barbaric
and and for people to think that it's
not true and it's just conservatives are
complaining how many liberals have been
banned how many livers are bad for the
things they say they can come out and
say I hate
they could come out and say Don Lemon on
CNN said the biggest threat to America
is the white man the straight white male
that that it to me if you said the
biggest threat to America is the
straight black man they will ban you on
everything they'll call you a racist
they'll throw you out of the country so
he can say those things
uh the actor I forget her name she's a
comedian Kathy Griffin she had a a a
beheaded Donald Trump head in effigy he
it was like Donald Trump was beheaded
and it was Bloody it was his face it was
a it was a it was like a doll thing
she's showing the president of the
United States beheaded
and she don't lose none of her social
media platforms it's just it's like it's
clearly a problem and I think that it
really
what it does to a certain degree it's
very hard for them to do it but what it
does is it it changes the conversation
so you have people that are looking for
information but they don't never see the
conservative side because they're all
banned and Shadow band and all this
other stuff and then they only see these
liberals and they only see people saying
that oh drag queen story I was a good
thing women uh trans men should be able
to a trans women should be able to play
sports they only see that narrative so
they think that that most people believe
that so in reality when 99 of people are
like this is crazy this is crazy but
they're banned from any you know uh you
know access not all but in a lot of ways
the smaller channels get banned
yeah it's crazy I also had my Tick Tock
um taken down but then I appealed and I
got it back
um so I don't know maybe maybe try and
try appeal it um you mentioned you
mentioned um Donald Trump quite a few
times and you like him what do you think
is going to happen at the next election
do you think he's gonna run again do you
think DeSantis is gonna gonna run what
do you think's gonna happen I have and I
wish I could tell you I have no idea I
don't know what's going to happen with
this legal stuff I mean you could
clearly see they're attacking him yes
you know last year they could have FBI
could have came and got those uh
articles from the National Archive they
could have done a warrant the go to
Mar-A-Lago the the Attorney General I
think the Attorney General somebody uh
in New York suing him they could have
sued him uh a year ago two years ago the
student when he was the president of the
United States of America they could have
done all this but no they wait until he
announced or like he's he's the front
runner for the Republican Party in the
midterms he has endorsed all of these
candidates that are doing really well so
they they're attempting to take him out
and they're attempted to put furballist
lawsuits and all of this stuff to drag
his name through the dirt now I don't
know if anything's gonna stick because
they can find a way to create a
situation where he has to get arrested
yeah so outside of that I really do
believe that he's going to run again I
mean I don't see him not he's rallying
all over the country if he don't run
again I don't know who is he setting it
up he's setting up the layup for
DeSantis or what because the only two
valuable options in the Republican party
right now for president would be
DeSantis and Donald Trump and right now
any poll is showing that Donald Trump is
Leaps and Bounds above DeSantis
um but if he gets arrested or something
crazy like that then the sentence he's
gonna have to step in there and do it
and he would he would be love be beloved
by the nation and I think people in the
middle would now this is what I'll say
Let me let me just correct this
not corrected let me just expand on this
if Trump did not run and DeSantis ran
I believe that the Sanchez would would
not only dominate the Republican vote
but he'll get a lot of moderate and
people who are in between that will vote
for him and he will win the presidency
in a landslide I think now Donald Trump
is fiery
so he's not going to get Democrat no
Democrats you know I mean not Democrats
but you know like the people who are far
left yeah he's not with them he's not
going to get most people in the middle
he's going to get
Republicans turning out like never
before that's what he's going to get
he's going to get a republican base
that's turning out like never before all
the converts who are turning out like
never before is his path to success
um I think the scientists will be less
Extreme More of gathering people in the
middle because I know a lot of people
that just can't stand Trump I mean maybe
it's time they'll vote for him because
Biden is so bad but a lot of people just
can't stand Trump like I go to the Cigar
Lounge all the older guys in there like
I voted from 2016. I never vote for him
again and it blows my mind why they
would say that but it's real people are
actually believing that and and you know
but I think that Trump did very very
well in 2020 I think there were some
weird things that went on but I think it
did very very well
yeah I agree I think DeSantis is a
character which would uh unify people
Trump is just too divisive he's too
you know they say he's not presidential
enough you know the language that he
uses and things like that yeah but you
know he he does get a lot of people like
him because he's just real you know but
stances is really good too but he's just
real he just tell you like it is it's a
fake news I'm gonna go and do this I'm
gonna take the embassy and put Embassy
in Jerusalem
you're like he went to Kim Jong-un he
went out there and had a conversation
with a Vladimir Putin and he yeah he's
just real like buy this reader Biden is
reading something somebody wrote on a
teleprompter you don't know what he
really feel like you don't know what
he's really gonna do you don't know
what's strategic was so I think a lot of
people like that Trump is just don't
give a f and I think a lot of people
feel like he do like I'm sick of these
politicians just get in there and kill
it be a businessman get us back on track
make it happen I don't care what you
tweet I may not like your tweets but I
like your policies we can do a give or
take but with the senses being in a fold
I think that it it does challenge
people's
um idea of saying well maybe we have
another choice we may not have to have a
polarizing figure but let me just say
this they're going to do the sentence
the same way they did Trump they have to
the Santa is going to come out and be a
racist some women are going to come and
say DeSantis raped them when he was 18
years old uh in in a dream that they had
you know what I'm saying so they're
going to come out against them because
they have to to win
yeah no it makes a lot of sense I saw um
sonovich actually tweeted
um this 22 this 2022 midterm is life or
death you either understand the stakes
or you don't do you agree do you think
it's pretty scary oh yeah it is it is it
is it is it is it's 100 Republicans need
to get their foot back into the House of
Representatives and also they need to
dominate in the Senate because these
Democrats are gonna I mean we see things
you see you see what's happening with
the Keystone Pipeline inflation gas
prices going up this is a direct policy
issue and Democrats they don't care
about
what's happening to us because the end
justifies the means they don't care if
our country go to crowd they don't care
their their goal is Ultimate control and
power and they want to separate the
classes they want everybody to be down
here eating off the government and the
wealthy to be up here as the elite they
don't want a middle class they want to
get rid of electoral college they want
to impact the Supreme Court so that
every liberal policy they push they can
push it through a leftist supreme court
just like they did Roe v Wade which
should which should have never been uh
uh in place in the first place we should
have never had roe it's not consistent
with the Constitution of the United
States of America thank God we finally
overturned it but you know it never was
consistent but this is what the Liberals
want to do they want to they want
ultimate power and if we don't stop them
they are going to do it and we're going
to turn into China and Venezuela
somewhere else where you see communism
running rampant
yeah
um I'm I'm I am like an optimistic
person but I don't know about the West I
don't know what's coming over the next
the next decade you know we don't stand
up it's gonna be gone even in Europe
you know the the the Muslim extremists
they just allowed them to come into the
country you know it's it's like if they
just being politically correct it's just
it's killing us political correctness is
killing us and and they're all for it
they are do you have any final any final
words any message that you want people
to uh sort of take away from from this
well be a be a free thinker go and do
research on your own don't believe the
first thing you hear don't even listen
to what I'm saying you know hear me but
verify the things that I say verify the
things that that you hear and and be
able to
a challenge or at least explain what you
believe that is the crucial Point even
when my with faith in God you know
because I'm a Christian you know every
day I say why am I not a Muslim why am I
not uh Jewish which I think I'm probably
more Jewish than Christian according to
the Christian ideology to be honest but
probably the modern Christianity
ideology but you know you be able to
defend your position and if you can't
then don't be out here arguing with
people you know go do some research
defend your position I also will say uh
relationship with God is not a religion
relationship with God is a relationship
it's a personal relationship that can be
developed and I want people to
understand that because a lot of people
get turned away from religion because
they don't want to wear to yamaka or
they feel like that the Sabbath is too
much to do or they feel like going to
church every Sunday is too much for them
to handle I just want people to
understand that that's not what
relationship with God is relationship
with God is a personal dedicated
relationship every single day not just
on holidays and and on Saturdays or
Sundays
yeah no I think that's beautifully put
um where can people follow you and find
out all of your stuff what you're up to
find out more about black sip
yeah so if you go to the officer
tatum.com the t-h-e officer tatum.com
that's my website and everything I do is
on my website my merge my my media my uh
syndicated radio show on Salem my
podcast YouTube everything you can find
for me and you can contact me if you
want to contact me there's a contact tab
if you want to book me there's a book
tab everything is on my website the
officer tatum.com
guys go follow Brandon Tatum he is doing
some amazing things
um I love the uh you know the education
that you're doing the way you're trying
to inspire um inspire people and Empower
them to think for themselves and get
educated I think that's amazing so
Brandon thank you so much for coming on
it's been such a pleasure speaking to
you
and thank you so much for having me it
was such an incredible pleasure to be
here and and out of out of the people
that I've done podcast with you are one
of my favorites so thank you so much I
appreciate that thank you so much guys
please don't forget to hit the Subscribe
button follow Brandon and we will see
you all next week bye bye the Leia plan
show